안녕하세요, 저는 Olivia Lanes예요. 양자 컴퓨팅 실전 강좌에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 오늘은 에피소드 2, Quantum
circuits편이에요. 오늘 강의에서는 여러 주제를 다룰 건데요, 여러분이 꼭 알고 가셨으면 하는 세 가지가 있어요. 첫 번째는 IBM
양자 컴퓨터가 실제로 어떤 건지예요. 클라우드를 통해 작업을 보낼 때 머릿속에 대략적인 그림이라도 그릴 수 있도록요.
두 번째는 Qiskit이 뭔지, Primitives가 뭔지, 그리고 이걸 어떻게 활용해서 Quantum circuits를 만들고 실행하는지예요.
IBM Quantum 프로세서의 종류와 각각의 차이점에 대해서도 큰 그림에서 살펴볼 거예요. 그리고 세 번째는
대규모 실험을 실행하기 위해 따르는 일반적인 워크플로우예요. 여기에는 최적의 Primitives 선택이 포함돼요.
여러분의 용도에 맞게 문제를 Quantum circuit에 매핑하고, 오류 억제 및 완화를 적용하는 것도 포함되는데, 이를 통해
이 기계들에서 최대한의 성능을 뽑아낼 수 있어요. 정보가 많긴 하지만 저와 함께 계속 가봐요.
곧 실제 예시들을 통해 모든 걸 종합해서 볼 거예요. 먼저 qubit과 실제 Quantum
하드웨어에 대해 간단히 살펴봐요. 실험가로서 말씀드리면, 정말 매력적인 분야예요. 점들을 연결하는 데 실제로 큰 도움이 되거든요.
클라우드를 통해 양자 컴퓨터에 작업이 전송될 때 실제로 어떤 일이 일어나는지 시각화할 수 있어요. 우리가
사용할 프로세서들은 초전도 트랜스몬 qubit으로 만들어져 있어요. 작은 IBM quantum 프로세서가 어떻게 생겼는지 보여드릴게요.
여기 작은 사각형들이 바로 qubit들이에요. 이 칩에는 총 다섯 개가 있어요. 트랜스몬은
커패시터인데, 비선형 인덕터인 조세프슨 접합과 병렬로 연결된 두 개의 금속판으로 구성돼 있어요.
조세프슨 접합을 보려면 훨씬 더 확대해야 해요. 두 개의
초전도 금속 층이 겹쳐진 곳에서 만들어지는데, 두 부분이 겹쳐서 닿는 곳이 접합부예요. 조세프슨
접합은 여러 에너지 레벨을 가진 인공 원자를 만드는 데 사용되는 소자예요. 우리는
아래쪽 두 에너지 레벨을 qubit 상태로 격리해요. 여기 구불구불한 선들은 마이크로파 공진기를 나타내는데,
기본적으로 qubit에 결합된 2D 전송선이에요. 이제 gate를 프로그래밍할 때 이건 기본적으로
정밀하게 보정된 마이크로파 펄스를 선택하는 거예요. 그 펄스의 특정 주파수, 진폭, 형태, 지속 시간이
qubit이 특정 동작을 하게 만들어요. 마이크로파 펄스에 대한 명령은 여러분의 컴퓨터에서 클라우드로 전달되고,
그런 다음 실온 제어 전자 장치가 읽고 해석해서 그 명령을 물리적으로
펄스로 생성해요. 이걸 마이크로파 펄스라고 부르는 건 전부 마이크로파 주파수 대역 안에 있기 때문이에요.
대략 1GHz 정도예요. 실온 제어 박스에서 펄스가 만들어지면 케이블을 통해 이동해요.
희석 냉동기를 거쳐 최종적으로 Quantum 칩에 도달해요. 신호는 공진기로 들어가는데,
이 패드 위의 와이어 본드를 통해 들어가서 전송선을 따라 qubit으로 흘러가요. 이게 조금
기술적으로 느껴질 수 있고, 앞으로 나아가는 데 이 세부 사항들을 꼭 이해해야 하는 건 아니에요. 하지만 이제
여러분 모두가 곧 상호작용하게 될 물리적 시스템을 어느 정도 머릿속에 그릴 수 있게 됐으면 해요. 그럼 이 양자 컴퓨터들은
실제로 어디에 있을까요? IBM은 전 세계에 수십 대의 양자 컴퓨터를 보유하고 있어요. 최근에는 Fleet을
100qubit 이상 프로세서로만 업그레이드했어요. 이전 강의에서 말씀드렸듯이, 일부는 IBM의
Quantum 데이터 센터(뉴욕 업스테이트)에 위치해 있어요. 그 시스템들은 모든 사람이 사용할 수 있도록 클라우드 전반에 배포돼 있고, 일부는
파트너사를 지원하는 온프레미스 전용 시스템으로, 작동에 필요한 모든 전자 장비를 갖추고 있어요.
IBM quantum 네트워크에 속한 파트너사들을 위한 거예요. 이제 Qiskit에 대해 얘기해 볼게요. IBM의 오픈소스 소프트웨어 개발 키트예요.
양자 컴퓨터에서 작동하도록 설계됐어요. 앞으로는 이걸 Qiskit SDK라고 부를게요. Qiskit
생태계도 있는데, Qiskit의 핵심 기능을 기반으로 하거나 확장하는 소프트웨어, 튜토리얼, 기능들의 모음이에요. 그리고 Qiskit
runtime도 있어요. 이건 사용자가 Quantum 워크로드를 설계하고 효율적으로
실행할 수 있게 해주는 Quantum Computing 서비스이자 프로그래밍 모델이에요. Qiskit Primitives를 사용하는데요, Primitive는 기본적으로 작은 빌딩 블록이에요.
더 큰 circuit이나 작업을 설계하는 데 사용할 수 있어요. 우리에게 가장 중요한 두 Primitive는
sampler와 estimator인데, 곧 더 자세히 다룰 거예요. Qiskit SDK를 아직 다운로드하고 설치하지 않으셨다면,
지금이 딱 좋은 때예요. Qiskit 1.0이 최근 출시됐는데, 이전보다 훨씬 더 성능이 좋고
안정적이에요. 막 시작하시는 분들에게는 정말 좋은 타이밍에 오신 거예요. 이미 Qiskit에 익숙하신 분들은
최신 버전을 다운로드해서 재설치하셔야 해요. pip을 사용해서 Qiskit과 Qiskit runtime을 설치하고,
원하는 웹 브라우저에서 Jupyter 노트북을 통해 실행하는 걸 권장해요. 그래서 Jupyter notebook이나 Jupyter lab도
설치하셔야 해요. 아직 안 하셨다면요. 이 도구들은 모두 무료예요.
비용 없이 여러분의 로컬 머신에서 실행할 수 있어요. visualization 옵션 의존성과 함께 Qiskit을 추가해서
Jupyter에서 잘 작동하고 플롯을 그릴 수 있게 해야 해요. 가상 Python 환경도 설정해야 하는데,
여기에 링크된 Qiskit 설치 페이지에 방법이 나와 있어요. Qiskit에 익숙해지고
실제 양자 컴퓨터에서 작업을 실행할 준비가 됐다면 quantum.com에 등록하고 IBM Quantum
API 토큰을 만들어야 해요. 이에 대한 링크도 여기 있어요. 이 방법에 대한 자세한 안내는
제가 말씀드린 것처럼 문서 페이지의 모든 지침을 따라가시거나, 여기 있는 Qiskit 설치 코딩 영상을 보셔도 돼요.
두 곳 다 설명란에 링크가 있어요. 이제 Quantum
circuits에 대해 얘기할 준비가 거의 다 됐어요. 이 강좌의 목적은 여러분이 100qubit 이상의 규모로
작업을 실행할 수 있도록 가르치는 거예요. 그러기 위해 가장 효과적인 방법은 먼저 우리가 따를 전체 워크플로우를 살펴보는 거라고 생각해요. 이를 이해하는 가장 쉬운 방법이
Qiskit patterns예요. Qiskit patterns는 사용자가 모듈식 툴링으로 특정 단계를 구현해서 Quantum
워크로드를 실행할 수 있게 해주는 개념적 프레임워크예요. 이를 통해 Quantum Computing 작업이
강력한 이기종 컴퓨팅 인프라로 수행될 수 있어요. 이 단계들은 서비스로 수행될 수 있고
리소스 관리를 포함할 수 있어요. 이를 통해 새로운 기능이 개발됨에 따라 원활하게 구성될 수 있어요. 여기
주요 단계들이 있는데, 경험 있는 Qiskit 사용자라면 이미 알고 계실 거예요. 첫 번째 단계는 매핑이에요. 이 단계에서는
관심 있는 일반적인 문제를 어떻게 양자 컴퓨터에
circuit 형태로 매핑할지 공식화해요. 다음은 최적화예요. 이 단계에서는 Qiskit transpiler를 사용해서 circuit을 라우팅하고
실제 물리적 Quantum 하드웨어에 배치해요. 여기에는 개별 Quantum gate를 시퀀스로 변환하는 것도 포함돼요.
하드웨어에서 수행되는 연산들뿐만 아니라 해당 gate들의 레이아웃 최적화도 포함돼요. 다음은
실행 단계예요. Qiskit runtime Primitives는 IBM Quantum 하드웨어와의 인터페이스를 제공해서 transpile된 circuit을 실행할 수 있게 해줘요.
이 단계에는 오류 억제 및 완화 기법 사용도 포함되는데, 이는 대부분 사용자가 신경 쓰지 않아도 되게끔 추상화돼 있어요. 마지막으로 후처리 단계예요.
이 단계에서는 양자 프로세서 자체의 데이터를 처리해서 원래 문제에 대한 유용한 결과를 사용자에게 제공해요. 기본적으로 이 단계는
취득한 데이터에 대한 추가 분석을 모두 포함해요. 이제 Quantum
프로그램의 기초인 quantum circuit에 대해 얘기할 준비가 됐어요. Quantum circuit에 대해 이미 알고 계신 분도 있겠지만, 혹시 모르신다면 먼저 강의
3편 Quantum circuits를 확인해 보세요. 아래에 링크된 'Quantum 정보와 계산 이해하기'의 일부예요. 여기서는
간단하게 복습만 할 거예요. Quantum circuit은 quantum gate와 측정의 네트워크로,
qubit을 나타내는 선으로 연결돼 있어요. Quantum circuit은 악보처럼 왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 읽을 수 있어요.
맨 왼쪽이 시간 0이에요. 가상 qubit, 즉 아직 프로세서의 실제 물리적 qubit에 할당되지 않은 qubit은
위에서 아래로 오름차순으로 나열돼요. circuit을 설정한 다음에는 gate를
추가할 수 있어요. 여기 Hadamard gate처럼 단일 qubit gate는 해당 선이 놓인 qubit에만 영향을 미쳐요. 다중 qubit
gate는 이 CNOT처럼 gate로 연결된 두 개 이상의 qubit에 영향을 미쳐요. 이 예시에서 qubit 1의 상태는
qubit 0의 상태에 따라 달라져요. 모든 gate가 적용된 후에 측정을 수행할 수 있는데,
측정 결과가 고전 레지스터에 기록되게 해요. circuit의 특히 중요한 특성 중 하나는
depth예요. quantum circuit의 depth는 circuit이 정의하는 계산을 완료하는 데 필요한 병렬 실행 quantum gate 레이어의 최솟값이에요.
명확히 말씀드리면, Quantum gate는 공통 qubit이 없을 때마다
병렬로, 즉 정확히 동시에 실행될 수 있어요. 하지만 두 개 이상의
gate가 동일한 qubit에 작용하면 병렬로 수행할 수 없고, 하나씩 순차적으로 수행해야 해요. Quantum gate는 구현하는 데 시간이 걸리기 때문에
circuit의 depth는 대략 양자 컴퓨터가 해당 circuit을 실행하는 데 필요한 시간에 해당해요.
따라서 circuit의 depth를 알면 특정 기기에서 실행 가능한지 아닌지 알 수 있어요. 또한
정확한 결과를 낼 가능성이 있는지도 알 수 있어요. 다음으로 Quantum 프로세서 선택으로 넘어가 볼게요. IBM은
최근 100qubit 이상의 프로세서로 이루어진 완전히 새로운 Fleet을 출시했어요. quantum.com에 로그인하면
어떤 프로세서에 액세스할 수 있는지 확인할 수 있어요. 프로세서들은 모두 새의 이름을 따서 지었어요. 나름의 이유가 있고, 각각 다른 로고가
다른 종류의 프로세서를 나타내요. 예를 들어, 이것들은 Eagle 프로세서를 나타내고, 이 아이콘은
Heron이에요. 특정 프로세서의 이름도 상단에 있는데, 모두 도시 이름을 따서 지었어요. 하지만
그렇다고 해서 프로세서가 반드시 그 도시에 물리적으로 위치한 건 아니에요. 그냥 이름일 뿐이에요. qubit 수,
EPPG, CLOPS도 모두 나열된 요소들이에요. 각각에 대해 살펴볼게요.
qubit 수는 꽤 자명해요. 해당 Quantum 프로세서, 즉
QPU에서 사용 가능한 전체 qubit 수예요. EPPG는 레이어드 gate 오류율을 나타내는데, 100qubit의 레이어드 체인에서 평균 gate 처리 오류를 측정해요.
기본적으로 값이 작을수록 좋아요. CLOPS는 초당 circuit 레이어 연산을 나타내고,
QPU가 단위 시간당 Quantum volume circuit(가상 circuit)의 레이어를 몇 개나 실행할 수 있는지 측정해요.
숫자가 높을수록 계산이 빠른 거예요. 이건 고전 컴퓨팅의 FLOPS와 동일한 개념이에요. 이
다양한 지표들은 관심 있는 특정 응용 분야에 따라 더 중요하거나 덜 중요할 수 있어요. 다음으로 큰 그림에서
Quantum circuit으로의 매핑에 대해 살펴볼게요. 첫 번째 단계는 매핑 단계인데, 기본적으로 이런 질문에 답하는 거예요. 어떻게
내 문제를 Quantum 하드웨어에서 실행할 수 있는 Quantum circuit으로 변환할 수 있을까? 확실히
매핑은 어려운 문제예요. 활발한 연구 분야이기도 하고요. 때로는 단순히 계산
문제를 가져다가 이를 해결하는 데 도움이 되는 quantum gate 시퀀스를 만들어내는 것이 가장 어려운 부분이에요. 성공을 보장하는 확실한
방법은 없지만, 권장 가이드라인과 이미 매핑하는 방법을 알고 있는 문제들의 예시가 있어요.
첫 번째 가이드라인은 고전 컴퓨터가 더 잘하는 건 고전 컴퓨터에게 맡기라는 거예요. 고전 컴퓨터에게 쉬운
작업은 아마 양자 컴퓨터의 혜택을 받지 못할 거예요. 양자 컴퓨터는 고전적으로 어려운 문제들을 위한 거예요. 물론
Qiskit이나 양자 컴퓨터를 처음 사용하시는 분이라면, 계산적으로 복잡한 문제를 찾는 걱정은 안 하셔도 돼요. 더 작은 문제들로 분해해서
유틸리티 규모 프로젝트로 바로 가기 전에 먼저 배워 나가세요. 다음으로
측정하거나 이해하고 싶은 문제의 결과를 기댓값 문제나 샘플링
문제로 변환해요. 대부분의 문제 유형에서 이는 기본적으로 비용 함수를 계산하는 것에 해당해요. 비용 함수는
문제의 목표를 최소화하거나 최대화해야 할 대상으로 정의하는 문제별 함수예요. 또한
시험 상태나 솔루션이 그 목표에 얼마나 잘 수행되는지 확인하는 데 사용될 수 있어요.
이 개념은 화학, 머신러닝, 금융, 최적화 등 다양한 응용 분야에 적용될 수 있어요.
또한 사용할 하드웨어에는 특정 토폴로지가 있다는 점도 명심해야 해요. 연결된 qubit도 있고
연결되지 않은 qubit도 있어요. 결국 여러분의 문제를 이를 나타내는 circuit에 매핑해야 해요. IBM Quantum 프로세서는
heavy hex 토폴로지라는 것을 사용하는데, 이는 기본적으로 hexagonal 격자에서의 qubit 연결에 해당해요.
이에 대해서는 나중에 강좌에서 더 자세히 다룰 거예요. 지금 당장 가장 중요하게 명심할 것은 이 단계에는
연습이 필요하다는 거예요. 자신의 문제만이 아니라 Quantum 하드웨어의
기능에 대해서도 잘 이해해야 해요. 나중에 구체적인 예시와 사용 사례를 통해 이것들을 어떻게 잘
균형 잡을 수 있는지 살펴볼 거예요. 이제 선택한 하드웨어에 맞게 circuit을 최적화하는 방법을 살펴봐요. 최적화 단계의 전체적인 목표는
circuit의 모든 가상 qubit을 프로세서 토폴로지 어딘가에 있는 실제 qubit에
매핑하는 거예요. 핵심은 오류를 최대한 줄이는 거예요. 이를 위해 먼저 circuit을
효율적으로 라우팅하고 배치해야 해요. 우선 모든 qubit이 연결돼 있는 건 아니라는 점을 명심해야 해요.
이미 말씀드렸듯이, 칩 위에서 실제로 서로 멀리 떨어진 qubit도 있어요. 그래서 장거리
상호작용을 최대한 줄이거나 없애야 해요. 인접한 qubit 사이에 swap gate 시퀀스를 적용해서 qubit
정보를 이동시킬 수 있지만, swap gate는 비용이 많이 들고 오류가 발생하기 쉬워요. 더 나은 방법이 있을 수 있어요. 다음으로 레이아웃
라우팅은 반복적인 과정이에요. 가상 qubit을 하드웨어의 물리적 qubit에
circuit으로 할당해요. 수동으로 할 수도 있지만, Qiskit에는 근사 오류율을 기반으로 물리적
qubit 레이아웃을 추천해주는 도구도 있어요. 다음으로 같은 qubit에 작용하는 단일 qubit gate 시퀀스를
단일 gate로 합칠 수 있어요. 또한 불필요한 gate나 gate 조합을 제거할 수도 있어요. 예를 들어
일부 gate 조합은 더 간단한 조합으로 줄일 수 있고, 때로는 gate 조합이
단순한 항등 연산자와 같아지기도 해요. 그러면 그냥 제거하면 돼요. Qiskit
transpiler를 사용해서 자동으로 할 수도 있고, 더 많은 제어를 원하거나 그럴 만한 이유가 있다면 gate별로 수동으로 할 수도 있어요.
수동으로든 Qiskit transpiler를 사용해서든 circuit 레이아웃, 라우팅, gate 수를 개선한 후에는
보통 circuit을 시각화해서 모든 gate의 타이밍이 맞는지 확인하고 싶어요. transpiler에 플래그를 사용해서
circuit의 타임라인을 시각화하고 모든 것이 예상대로 정렬돼 있는지 확인할 수 있어요. 이제 오류
억제에 대해 얘기해 봐요. 오류 억제는 컴파일 중에 오류를 최소화하기 위해 circuit을 변환하는 다양한 기법을 말해요.
이건 circuit이 이미 실행된 후에 이루어지는 오류 완화와는 다른 개념이에요. 곧 그것도 다룰 거예요. 가장 일반적인
두 가지 오류 억제 기법은 dynamical decoupling과 Pauli twirling이에요.
기술적인 세부 사항이 좀 있지만, 나중에 다시 참고하실 수 있어요. 첫 번째로 dynamical decoupling은
XX 시퀀스처럼 합쳐서 항등 연산이 되는 일련의 gate를 적용해서
qubit에 영향을 미치는 노이즈를 효과적으로 상쇄하는 데 사용돼요. 이 gate들의 순 효과는 qubit에 영향을 미치는 노이즈 채널을 근사적으로 상쇄하는 거예요.
Pauli twirling은 랜덤 gate를 삽입해서 평균 노이즈를 단순화하는 방법이에요. 무작위성은
서로 다른 오류들의 영향이 빠르게 누적되는 걸 방지하고 노이즈를 특성화하기도 더 쉽게 만들어줘요.
이 방법은 오류 완화 기법의 기초도 형성하는데, 나중에 다시 다룰 거예요.
다시 말씀드리지만, 정보가 많고 모든 게 바로 이해되지 않아도 걱정 마세요. 다행히 이 중 많은 부분이 Qiskit
transpiler를 사용해서 자동으로 할 수 있어요. transpilation은 까다로울 수 있지만, 대규모에서 유용성을 달성하는 데 매우 중요한 단계라서
숙달하고 최선의 결과를 얻으려면 많은 시행착오가 필요해요. 잠깐
Qiskit transpiler와 그 기능에 대해 좀 더 자세히 살펴볼게요. 매우 큰 그림에서 다룰 거고, 나중에 세부 사항과 예시를
살펴볼 거예요. 일반적으로 transpilation은 주어진 입력 circuit을
특정 Quantum 기기의 토폴로지에 맞게 재작성하고 실행과 노이즈 내성을 위해 circuit을 최적화하는 과정이에요. 또한
주어진 circuit을 사용하기로 선택한 특정 Quantum 프로세서의 basis gate로 재작성해요. Qiskit에는 네 개의
내장 transpilation 파이프라인이 있는데, Quantum circuit 최적화에 익숙하지 않으시다면 그중 하나를 사용하는 걸 강력 추천해요.
내장 파이프라인 중 하나를요. 기본적으로 transpiler는 이 여섯 단계를 포함해요: 초기화,
레이아웃, 라우팅, 변환, 최적화, 스케줄링. 초기화는
circuit을 backend에 임베딩하기 전에 필요한 초기 패스를 말해요. 여기에는 보통
커스텀 명령어를 펼치고 circuit을 단일 및 이중 qubit gate로만 변환하는 게 포함돼요. 레이아웃 단계에서는
circuit의 가상 qubit을 backend의 물리적 qubit에 매핑하는 레이아웃을 적용해요. 라우팅은 레이아웃이 적용된 후에 실행되고
swap gate 같은 gate를 원래 circuit에 삽입해서 backend의
연결성과 호환되게 만들어요. 네 번째 단계는 변환인데, 이 단계에서 circuit의 gate들이 대상
backend의 basis set으로 변환돼요. 다음은 최적화예요. 이 단계에서는 특정 목표 depth에 도달하는 것과 같은 조건이 충족될 때까지 주요 최적화
루프를 반복 실행해요. 선택할 수 있는 최적화 레벨이 네 가지 있어요.
마지막은 스케줄링이에요. 이 단계는 하드웨어 인식 스케줄링 패스를 위한 거예요. 큰 그림에서 스케줄링은 명령어 실행
사이에 qubit의 유휴 시간을 반영하기 위해 circuit에 지연을 삽입하는 것으로 생각할 수 있어요.
앞서 말씀드렸듯이, 최적화 레벨은 0부터 3까지 네 단계가 있는데, 높은 최적화 레벨일수록 더 많은 시간과 계산 노력이 필요하지만 더 나은 circuit을 얻을 수 있어요.
최적화 레벨 0은 기기 특성화 실험을 위한 것으로, 입력 circuit을
대상 backend의 제약에만 매핑해요. 어떤 최적화도 수행하지 않아요. 최적화 레벨 3은
circuit 최적화에 가장 많은 노력을 기울여요. 하지만 transpiler의 최적화 기법 중 많은 부분이
휴리스틱 기반이라서 더 많은 계산 노력을 투입해도 항상 더 좋은 출력 circuit을
만들어내는 건 아니에요. 이 부분이 더 궁금하시다면 아래 링크된 Qiskit
문서의 transpiler 페이지를 확인해 보세요. 이제 Quantum circuit의 실제 실행에 대해 얘기할 준비가 됐어요.
Qiskit runtime Primitives는 IBM Quantum 하드웨어와의 인터페이스를 제공하고, 오류
억제와 완화도 사용자로부터 추상화해줘요. sampler primitive는 특정 비트 문자열(0과 1)을 측정할 가능성을 나타내는 준확률 분포나 카운트를 반환해요.
estimator primitive는 물리량에 해당하는 관측값의 기댓값을 반환해요.
조금 더 자세히 말씀드리면, sampler는 Quantum 기기에서 circuit을
여러 번 실행해서 각 실행마다 측정을 수행하고 해당 비트 문자열을 복구해서 확률
분포를 구성해요. 실행 횟수, 즉 shots가 많을수록 결과가 더 정확해지지만,
더 많은 시간과 Quantum 리소스가 필요해요. 구체적으로는 circuit이 준비한 상태를 측정해서
각 가능한 표준 기저 상태를 얻을 확률을 계산해요. Qiskit의
estimator는 복잡한 대수 과정을 사용해서 실제 Quantum 기기에서 기댓값을 추정하는데,
관측값을 알려진 고유 기저를 가진 다른 관측값들의 조합으로 분해하고 실행해요.
Primitives의 내부에는 오류 완화라는 기법들이 있어요. 오류 완화는 이 모든 것의 포괄적인 용어로,
기본적으로 실행 시점에 기기 노이즈를 모델링해서 circuit 오류를 줄이는 기법들을 말해요.
보통 이로 인해 모델 훈련과 관련된 Quantum 전처리 오버헤드와 고전
후처리 오버헤드가 발생해요. 생성된 모델을 사용해서 원시 결과의 오류를 완화하는 거죠. 하지만 이 오버헤드의 대가로
훨씬 더 정확한 결과를 얻을 수 있어요. 구현할 수 있는 기법이 여러 가지 있어요.
오버헤드와 교환해서 더 정확한 결과를 얻을 수 있어요. 구현할 수 있는 여러 기법이 있어요.
오류 완화 기법들이 있는데, 그중 세 가지를 더 자세히 살펴볼 거예요. 하지만 이 분야는
활발한 연구 분야라서 새로운 기법들이 계속 개발될 것이고 기존 기법들도 계속 개선될 거예요.
resilience 레벨이 높아질수록 비용, 즉 작업 실행에 걸리는 시간도 늘어나요. 이미 말씀드렸듯이,
resilience 레벨 0에서 transpiler는 circuit에 별다른 작업을 하지 않아요. 하지만 resilience 레벨 1부터는 twirled
readout error extinction, 줄여서 T-REX라는 기법이 도입돼요. T-REX는 Pauli twirling을 사용해서
노이즈를 완화하는데, 이미 살펴봤던 내용이에요. 직관적으로 말씀드리면 노이즈를 덜 불규칙하고 다루기 쉽게 만드는 매우 일반적이고 효과적인 기법이에요.
resilience 레벨 2부터는
zero noise extrapolation, 줄여서 ZNE가 도입돼요. 최근 많은 성과를 거두고 있는 인기 있는 기법이에요.
ZNE의 아이디어는 좀 놀랍게 느껴질 수 있는데요, 실제로 이미 있는 노이즈 위에
추가 노이즈를 더 얹어요. 하지만 이렇게 하면 반대 방향으로 외삽해서
노이즈가 더 적었을 때 결과가 어떻게 나올지 예측할 수 있어요. 몇 가지 구체적인 방법으로 할 수 있는데, 예를 들어
gate를 늘려서 더 길게, 즉 오류에 더 취약하게 만들 수 있어요. 또는 최종적으로
항등 연산이 되는 gate를 더 실행할 수 있어요. circuit이 기능적으로는 실제로 변하지 않지만 의도적으로 더 많은
노이즈를 샘플링하는 거예요. 하지만 추적하려는 모든 circuit과 모든 기댓값에 대해 이걸 해야 하므로
시간 측면에서 매우 비용이 많이 들 수 있어요. ZNE의 특정 유형 중 하나를
probabilistic error amplification, 줄여서 PEA라고 해요. gate의 노이즈 모델을 학습한 후, PEA는 그 노이즈 모델에서
오류를 샘플링해서 의도적으로 circuit에 주입하는 방식으로 작동해요. 말씀드렸듯이, 새로운
기법들이 계속 개발되고 있고, 더 많은 기법이 도입되면 구현될 거예요. 마지막으로 한 가지 오류 완화 기법이 있는데,
probabilistic error cancellation이라고 해요. 세 번째 resilience
레벨에 있는 게 아니라, PEC는 Qiskit에서 수동으로 켜야 하는 특수 기능이에요. 필요한 계산 리소스가
다른 오류 완화 기법들에 비해 확장성이 좋지 않기 때문이에요. 먼저 circuit에 영향을 미치는 노이즈를
파악해야 해요. circuit에 있는 각 고유한 이중 qubit gate 레이어에 대해 노이즈 학습 또는 노이즈 특성화
circuit을 실행하는 거예요. 이 결과를 통해 노이즈를
Pauli 연산자 관점에서 설명할 수 있어요. 이 노이즈 항들을 알면 circuit을 수정해서
효과적으로 반대 PEC가 내장되어 이 노이즈 채널을 상쇄하게 만들 수 있어요. 어떤 면에서 이 과정은
노이즈 캔슬링 헤드폰과 비슷해요. 하지만 이 방식으로 노이즈를 되돌리는 건 gate 수에 따라 실행 시간이
기하급수적으로 증가해서 매우 비용이 많이 들어요. 따라서 매우 큰 circuit에는 최선의 선택이 아닐 수 있어요. 이제
마지막 단계인 후처리에 도달했어요. 결국 좋은 작업을 하고 적절한 오류
완화 기법을 적용했다면 이 그림처럼 최종 답이 달라지는 걸 볼 수 있어요. 여기 보라색으로 표시된 완화되지 않은 분포는
이 선으로 표시된 실제 기댓값과 꽤 멀리 있어요. 하지만 오류
완화를 적용하면 여기 파란색으로 표시된 완화된 분포를 얻게 되는데, 실제 값에 훨씬 더 가깝게 피크를 이뤄요. 하지만
이 모든 건 대가가 따르는데, 여기서 분포의 분산, 즉 너비가 증가하는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
일반적으로 원하지 않는 일이지만, 모든 것은 대가가 따르죠. 다행히 shots를 더 많이 실행해서
이를 해결할 수 있는데, 분포가 다시 허용 가능한 불확실성 수준으로 줄어들게 해요. 이번 강의는
여기까지예요. 다음 시간에는 이 모든 단계를 합쳐서 실제 응용 관심 분야의 예시를 통해 살펴볼 거예요.
그때까지 몇 가지 추천 사항이 있어요. 아직 안 하셨다면
Qiskit 1.0을 다운로드하고 설치해 보세요. IBM Quantum 학습 플랫폼에서 이 챕터의 관련 강의와
이전 에피소드도 확인해 보세요. 마지막으로 오류 완화 기법에 대해 더 깊이 파고들어
더 배우고 싶으시다면 아래에 링크한 다양한 자료들을 확인해 보세요. 그때까지 다음 시간에 봬요.
[음악]